بعد ثمانيه اشهر من انطلاق الثوره في
ليبيا وثلاثه ايام على مقتل العقيد
القذافي اعلن المجلس الوطني الانتقالي
تحرير كامل الاراضي الليبيه اذانا بطي
حقبه القذافي بشكل كامل وبدء مرحله
انتقاليه نحو تاسيس نظام ديمقراطي
وتكمن اهميه المرحله الانتقاليه بحسب
العديد من المراقبين في انها مرحله
الانتقال من الثوره الى الدوله وهي جسر
العبور من مرحله التحرير الى مرحله
التاسيس لدوله الدستور والمؤسسات
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في عنوانين
رئيسيين هل يرسم الاعلان الدستوري خارطه
طريق شامله للانتقال الى الديمقراطيه
ليبيا وما مدى قدره المجلس الوطني
الانتقالي على السيطره على انتشار السلاح
بعد اعلان التحرير
ولمناقشه هذا الموضوع مشاهدينا ينضموا
الينا من بنغازي عبد الحفيظ نائب رئيس
المجلس الوطني الانتقالي الليبي ومن
طرابلس ينضم الينا عز الدين عقيل الكاتب
والباحث السياسي
ولاحقا ينضم الينا من بنغازي انيس الشريف
المتحدث الاعلامي باسم المجلس العسكري
ومن خلال اعلان تحرير كامل ليبيا بحسب وصف
المجلس الوطني الانتقالي يبدا الانتقال من
مرحله الشرعيه الثوريه الى الشرعيه
الدستوريه حيث يتم بدء العمل بالاعلان
الدستوري الذي ينظم المرحله الانتقاليه
انطلاقا من تشكيل حكومه مؤقته والاعداد
لانتخاب مؤتمر وطني عام يكون بمثابه
البرلمان الانتقالي وصولا الى تشكيل هيئه
تاسيسيه لصياغه دستور دائم لليبيا واجراء
الانتخابات العامه
وكان العقود الاربعه لحكم القذافي لم تمر
وكان الليبيين ولدوا غداه استقلالهم الاول
ليعلنوا استقلالهم الثاني الثالث والعشرون
من تشرين الاول اكتوبر 2011 دخلت ليبيا
رسميا مرحله جديده
بحر من البشر في بنغازي التي اختيرت
تكريما لكونها بعد الثوره قرارات عمليه
وثلاثه في الخطاب تقدمت على ارباكات لحظات
النهايه التي رافقت السقوط التراجدي
للقذافي ونظامه الاعلان عن التحرير جاءك
اعلان ولاده لم يرث المحتفلون دوله او
نظاما وسيكون عليهم البدء من الصفر يكثر
التشكيك واحيانا التهويل من حجم التحديات
الان في ليبيا يشكل المجلس الانتقالي الذي
نشا بعد عشره ايام فقط من قيام الثوره
الذراعه التي ستتولى تنفيذ الخطوات
الاساسيه النظام الجديد العمليه تبدا من
لحظه اعلان التحرير سينتقل المجلس
الانتقالي واداراته الى طرابلس وخلال شهر
يجب تشكيل حكومه مؤقته وتنظيم انتخابات في
ثمانيه اشهر لتشكيل جمعيه تاسيسيه تضع
دستورا جديدا خلال 60 يوما من اول اجتماع
لها وسيخضع الدستور الاستفتاء قبل تنظيم
انتخابات تشريعيه النظام السياسي الليبي
الجديد سيكون مستقل من الشريعه الاسلاميه
وكان واضحا في الخطوات التي اعلنها مصطفى
عبد الجليل وقوبلت بترحيب كبير من الجمهور
مثل وقف التعامل بالربا شكل العقد
الاجتماعي المقبل بين الدوله الوليده
والناس في مواجهه ارتياب البعض من سيطره
التوجه الاسلامي يرى عارفون بالشان الليبي
بان ذلك ينسجم مع مجتمع متدين بطبيعته دون
خوف من تشدد او تعصب وبينما تبدو عمليه
الاعمار اقل التحديات صعوبه بوجود
احتياطات ليبيا الهائله من النفط والذهب
يرى كثيرون ان التحدي الابرز هو ترميم
النفوس بعد الحرب
اموالنا ودماؤنا واعراضنا حرام علينا
التسامح والعفو والصلح ونزع الحقد
والبغضاء والحسد والكراهيه من النفوس امر
ضروري لنجاح الثوره ولنجاح ليبيا المستقبل
قياده الثوار اعلنت ان تشكيلاتها المسلحه
ستعود الى التجمعات العسكريه وان الثوار
سيسلمون سلاحهم يتفائلوا الليبيون خيرا
بقدرتهم على تجاوز الصعوبات يفترض ذلك الى
جانب حسن النوايا قياده سياسيه تفرض
قراراتها بدءا بجمع السلاح وذلك مرهون
بتجاوز خلافات قد تنشب هنا وهناك على كبير
شان او صغيره ويرى كثر ان الاختلاف خلال
الايام الثلاثه الماضيه حول ما يتعين فعله
بجثه القذافي التي لم تدفن بعد نموذج لما
لا يجب ان تكون عليه الامور
اذا مشاهدينا ارحب بضيوفي من بنغازي عبد
الحفيظ غوقه نائب رئيس المجلس الوطني
للانتقالي الليبي ومن طرابلس عز الدين
عقيل الكاتب والباحث السياسي وامن بنغازي
ايضا انيس الشريف المتحدث الاعلامي باسم
المجلس العسكري وابدا معك سيد غوقه اذا
التحرير اعلنتم عنه اليوم امامكم تحديات
كبرى سياسيه وامنيه وعسكريه لكن ابرز تحدي
واكثر تحدي الحاحا اليوم هو
تشكيل حكومه انتقاليه خلال شهر من الان هل
من الممكن حصول ذلك
نعم اخي الكريم بكل تاكيد سنتمكن باذن
الله في المهله المحدده طبقا للماده 30
سنتمكن من تشكيل حكومه انتقاليه لتطلع في
اعباء المرحله ونحن على ثقه بان شعبنا
الذي خاض غمار حرب تحرير لكامل تراب الوطن
قادر باذن الله رغم الصعوبات والتحديات ان
يخوض غمار المرحله الانتقاليه اللاحقه وهي
مرحله بناء الدوله وبناء المؤسسات
ماذا نسمع في خلفيه الصوره سيد عبد العزيز
سيد غوقه عبد الحفيظ ماذا نسمع اطلاق رصاص
تعلم اخي الكبير ان هذا اليوم هو يوم
اعلان التحرير لكامل التراب الوطن فالفرحه
عارمه في ارجاء ليبيا ما بالك في مدينه
بني غازي التي اعلن منها التقرير فاصوات
الالعاب الناريه
والابتهاج تعم ارجاء ليبيا فاليوم ما لا
يقل عن 600 الى 700 الف
مواطن الاحتفالات في اعلان التحرير فالناس
خرجت الى الشوارع تحتفل وتحت في هذا ما
تسمعه في الخلفيه نعم على كل سيكون هذا
ايضا في المحور الثاني الحديث عن
التشكيلات العسكريه والموضوع الامني
واطلاق الرصاص وغير ذلك انما في الجزء
الثاني من هذه الحلقه لكن اشرت سيد غوكا
الى انه بالامكان خلال شهر تشكيل الحكومه
ولكن بحسب التجربه انه مضى شهران على
محاوله تشكيل حكومه او مجلس تنفيذي ولكن
لم
يفلح القاده الليبيون في ذلك كيف يمكن ان
ينجحوا في تشكيل الحكومه خلال شهر
لا اخي الكريم
هذه المقارنه غير دقيقه فنحن لم
نخفق في تشكيل مكتب تفيدنا احنا كونا مكتب
تنفيذي منذ
البدايات الثوره ثم لاسباب ودواعي يعرفها
الجميع
اعدنا تشكيل المكتب التنفيذي تاخر الامر
قليلا بعد ان
تطورت الاحداث وصولا الى تحرير العاصمه ثم
في نهايه المطاف تمكنا من اعاده تشكيل
المكتب التنفيذ حيث ابقينا على المكتب صف
مع تعديل طفي ولكن مساله الحكومه
الانتقاليه
سيعلن عنها باذن الله في في اجل غايته شهر
قد لا يقتضي منا الامر شهر نحن سنتقيد
بالاعلان الدستوري المهل والمدد المحدده
في العلم الدستوري سيتم راعاتها تماما
وستشكل الحكومه الانتقاليه في هذه المهله
ولن
باختصار باختصار ما هي معايير تشكيل هذه
الحكومه
والوطنيه
والرغبه هذه هي المعايير الاساسيه لن يكون
للمحاصصه الجهويه او
للايدولوجيات المختلفه
لن تكون معيارا في تشكيل الحكومه
الانتقاليه
سيده عز الدين عقيل يعني خلال شهر يجب ان
تشكل حكومه حسب الاعلان الدستوري لن يكون
هناك مخصصه جهويه ولا
مخصصه
لايديولوجيات هل تعتقد انه بالامكان ذلك
دعني بدايه اخي اهني الشعب الليبي العظيم
بهذا اليوم العظيم الذي توج الانتصار
الكبير لجهاد الشعب الليبي خاصه انه توافق
مع تتويج جهاد الشعب التونسي العظيم ببدء
الانتخابات التي ستؤسس الدوله المدنيه
الدستوريه في شقيقه تونس لاول مره ودعني
بدايه اقول بانني كنت اتوقع في احتفال
اليوم بمناسبه الاعلان التحرير ان يكون
هذا الاحتفال احتفال مهيب بشكل اكبر يليق
بهذه المناسبه الكبيره وان تكون وثيقه
التحرير هي وثيقه حقيقيه يوقعها اليوم
السيد مصطفى عبد الجليل بحضور ممثلين عن
منظمه الامم المتحده ومنظمه المؤتمر
الاسلامي والدفاع الاتحاد الافريقي
والجامعه العربيه وان تسلم لهم نسخ فعلا
هذه النسخ عن هذه الوثيقه التي كانت ستاذن
بانطلاق الدوله المدنيه الدستوريه وليس
هذا الحفل الذي جرى بالطريقه الشعبيه
اليوم لان الحقيقه كان يجب ان يكون هذا
الحفل يتماشى مع عظمه هذا اليوم في نفس
الوقت كنت اتمنى لو ان اعضاء المجلس
الانتقالي جميعا قدموا استقالاتهم في هذا
اليوم
يجب الحقيقه ان يعطوا دفعه كبيره باتجاه
تعزيز الثقه ثقه المواطن الليبي فيهم اذا
ما قاموا بالايثاء بهذا الوعد الذي وعدوا
به الشعب الليبي منذ فتره كنت اتمنى ايضا
ان نسمع بيان من رئيس الحكومه لماذا تغيب
عن هذا اليوم العظيم بيان ايضا من نفط
الديار او رئيس مجلس الافتاء في ليبيا
لماذا تغيب عن هذا اليوم هذا الحقيقه
اليوم عظيم كان يجب على هذه الشخصيات ان
تصدر بيانات تبين فيها موقفها ايضا
الحقيقه كانت بالنسبه لي صدمه كبيره ان
يقوم السيد نصفي عبد الجليل اليوم بالغاء
تشريع احدى التشريعات اللي هو تشريع تنظيم
الزواج في ليبيا اللي اعتقد انه قال انه
مخالف لشريعه الاسلاميه واعتقد ان
الكثيرين يخالفونه في هذا هذا التشريع هو
لتنظيم الزواج وليس لمنع الرجل من من تعدد
الزوجات وكان يجب مراعاه حقوق الزوجه في
هذا الجانب واعتقد ان هذا التشريع كان يجب
ان يلغيه الشعب الليبي وليس السيد
المستشار بمجرد قلم في احتفال طار كهذا
بالنسبه
لما تحدثت عنه اخي المعايير التي قال عنها
اخي عبد الحفيظ ليست معايير واحد يقول لك
الكفاءه والوطنيه كيف تعرف ان هذا اكثر من
هذا او ان هذا يزيد في الوطن كيف ستزن
الوطنيه الوطنيه ليست بالكيلو ولا بالجرام
حتى الحقيقه تشكيل الحكومات لابد ان يكون
لديه معايير اشد دقه وكان يجب الحقيقه ان
نسال هناك اداره سياسيه كبيره في الامم
المتحده لمساعده الدول الناشئه على في
مجال الديمقراطيات وكان يجب ان تساعدنا
مؤسسات المجتمع الدولي في هذا الاتجاه
اعتقد انه وفق الظروف التاليه سوف تكون
فعلا المحاصصه هي الاساس وسوف يكون
التاثير القبلي موجود وسوف تكون تاثير
العلاقات الخاصه والشخصيه موجوده في تشكيل
الحكومه للاسف كل ما طرحته سوف اعود
لاناقشه مع السيد عبد الحفيظ وقال ولكن
قبل ذلك سانتقل الى انيس الشريف المتحدث
الاعلامي باسم المجلس العسكري سيد الشريف
العمل العسكري والجانب العسكري كان حاسما
في هذه المعركه هل هذا برايك يعطي
المجلس العسكري حق المفاوضه والتدخل ايضا
في تشكيل الحكومه واخذ حصه من هذه الحكومه
المنتظره خلال 30 يوما
الحديث هنا ليس عن حصه او محاصصه بمقدار
هو محاوله او طلب ان يكون للثوار الذين
ابلو بلان حسنا في هذه الثوره وكانوا هم
راس الحربه في هذه الثوره التي ادت
بالاطاحه بنظام العقيد المنهاب
فالمطلوب هنا ليس حصه او قاسم لكعكه
سياسيه او ما شابه بمقدار هو محاوله بحث
عن اجماع وطني
ومحاوله انتزاج اراء جميع شركاء هذه
الثوره وهم في الحقيقه هم الشعب الليبي
باكمله لذلك المطلوب هو تداعي وطني ونقاش
وطني حول تشكيل هذه الحكومه من قبل كافه
شركاء الثوره والاطياف التي عملت بها وفي
مقدمتها الثوار على الارض الثوار لا
يطلبون مناصب بمقدار ما يطلبون ان يكونوا
في الصوره وان يتم مشاورتهم وليؤخذ ولم
يستمع الى رايهم باعتبار جزءا اساسي من
هذه الثوره المطلوب هو شخصيات وطنيه تقود
هذه تقود الشخصيه وطنيه تقود هذه الحكومه
وشخصيات وطنيه ذات كفاءه وقدره على تسير
المرحله الانتقاليه التي ستكون
الكلام عام ربما
الكلام
يكاد يكون عاما يعني ماذا تقصد باخذ راي
الثوار في اعضاء الحكومه في تشكيله
الحكومه يعني هل سيكون لهم حق الرفض او
تعطيل تشكيل الحكومه من من
لسبب او لاخر
ليس الحديث هنا عن الحق الرفض او الفيتو
او غيره بمقدار ما هو تداعي يعني المجلس
الوطني الانتقالي باعتباره
الممثل الشرعي والهيئه التشريعيه العليا
في البلاد عليه ان يستمع الى كل الاراضي
الشارع الليبي بما فيهما الثوار وغيرهم
وعليه ان
اعيان
المجتمع الليبي والى كافه الاطياف
الموجوده فيه وفي النهايه القرار بالتاكيد
سيكون هو قرار السلطه العليا في البلاد
لكن يجب ان ياخذ الاعتبار كل هذه الاراء
لا نريد لاحد بعد اربعه عقود من الاستبداد
من الاقصاء ان يكون ان يشعر احد طرف ما في
هذه الثوره بانه ليس جزءا من المستقبل
نريد ان نعبر الى المرحله القادمه ونحن
نشعر اننا جميعا شركاء في بناء الوطن وفي
بناء المستقبل كما كنا شركاء في هذه
الثوره على كل سنتابع هذا النقاش طبعا
مشاهدينا بعد الفاصل نواصل النقاش حول مدى
قدره المجلس الوطني الانتقالي السيطره على
فصائل الثوار وعلى انتشار الاسلحه ومناقشه
ما ورد في الجزء الاول ايضا من ميقات بعد
الفاصل ابقوا معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا في حلقتنا التي
تتناول اعلان تحرير كامل الاراضي الليبيه
واعود الى ضيوف من بنغازي عبد الحفيظ غوكا
السيد عبد الحفيظ استمعت الى السيده عز
الدين عقيل والتساؤلات التي طرحها وانتهى
فيها الى السؤال كيف يعلن رئيس المجلس
الانتقالي الغاء تشريع من دون العوده الى
الشعب أين الديمقراطيه في ذلك تفضل
قبل ان اجيب على السؤال دعني اصحح
للاستاذ عز الدين
قوله بانه كان على اعضاء المز وطن انتقالي
ان يستقيلوا اليوم
تنفيذا لوعدهم لا احد يقول ذلك على
الاطلاق اخي الكريم لا شعبنا ولا المرحله
تابى بان نلقي ببلدنا الى المجهول نحن
قلنا بانه بعد اعلان التحرير سنخوض غمار
مرحله انتقاليه لمده ثمانيه اشهر اشهر
عندها نسلم
الامور الى مؤتمر وطني منتخب وعند ذلك
تنتهي ولايه المسجد وطنه انتقالي ويستقيل
جميع اعضائه رئيس واعضاء
سينتهي دورهم عند انتخاب فهذه معلومه اردت
ان اصحح نحن لم نتخلف عن وعد قطعناه ولكن
المرحله تقتضي ذلك وهذا ما جاء عليه النص
راعه في الاعلان الدستوري هذا من ناحيه ما
تفضل بذكره
في المجلس الوطني انتقالي في كلمته التي
القاها اليوم انا اتفق مع الاستاذ عز
الدين بانه ليس بجره قلم يلغى يلغى قانون
او تسير وانا هنا اتحدث كرجل قانون
التشريعات ستظل ساريه نحن في المسجد
انتقالي لا نملك حق اصدار مثل هذه
القوانين ولا نملك حق الغاء اي تشريع من
التشريعات النافذه هذه وجهه نظر السيد
مشار عبر عنها اليوم قد تكون هذه الشخصيه
ولكن هذه يملكها
المؤتمر الوطني او تملكها الجمعيه الوطنيه
المنتخبه او البرلمان سميه
من اعلان الغاء غير ساري المفعول
لا بكل تاكيد هو غير ساري المفعول ولم
نملك نحن ان نعطل القوانين العمل بها
لماذا غادر رئيس الحكومه او رئيس الافتاء
عن عن هذا اليوم
المصير في البلاد
هو طبعا هذا يسال يسال عنه السيد رئيس
المكتب التنفيذي حضر عنه نائبه او وكيل
المكتب التنفيذي كان حاضرا وفعلا هو كان
هذا اليوم يجب ان لا يغيب عنه احد ايضا
نحن ارتئينا ان يكون احتفالا شعبيا اكثر
منه احتفال رسمي وثيقه او اعلان وثيقه
اعلان التحرير هي من الوثائق الهامه لتو
17 فبراير شانها شان بيانا انتصار الثوره
الذي صدر في الايام الاولى لثوره شانها
شان وثيقه تاسيس المجلس الانتقالي
والاعلان الدستوري ثم وثيقه اعلان التحرير
هذه من الوثائق الهامه والتي ستكون من
وثائق الثوره 17 فبراير سيده عز الدين
عقيل ونحن نستمع الى السيد غوقه نسمع
اصوات اطلاق رصاص ابتهاجا طبعا واصوات
انفجارات هذا يطرح تساؤل عن مدى امكانيه
ضبط الثوار وضبط المس لحين خصوصا واننا
امام كنا امام تصريحات في اليومين
الماضيين للسيد محمود جبريل يتحدث عن
الخوف من الفوضى في ليبيا
طبعا هذا هو التحدي الاكبر امام الليبيين
الان التحدي الاكبر هو كيف يسيطرون على
هذا السلاح المارق الموجود خارج الشرعيه
بشكل كبير كمن ونوعا وكيف يسيطرون على
المجموعه الميليشيات والمجموعات المسلحه
الكثيره المستقله الان التي لا تعود الى
اطراف سياسيه معينه لا اعتقد انها تدار
بواسطه المجلس الانتقالي علينا ان نفكر في
كيفيه ادماج هؤلاء الثوار في الحياه
الاجتماعيه من جديد ادماج هذه المليشيات
او الجماعات المسلحه في الجيش الوطني او
الامن الوطني هذا تحدي كبير ولا اعتقد بان
هذا التحدي يمكن انجازه دون تشكيل حكومه
مركزيه في البلاد التحدي الاكبر الان هو
التشكيل حكومه مركزيه في البلاد واعتقد
اننا سنواجه مشكله كبيره في هذا الاتجاه
بسبب ان مؤسسه المجلس الانتقالي صدرت
الحقيقه في ظروف شديده الصعوبه وهذه
المؤسسه الان فقيره جدا في قدرتها على
استيعاب كل التيارات وكل الاطراف التي
تريد ان تشارك الان في في حكم البلاد كل
الاطراف خاصه عدد كبير من من شباب الثوار
اليوم الحقيقه عندهم كينونه سياسيه
ويريدون ان يشاركوا في في صناعه القرار في
بلدانهم المشكله الكبير الان امامنا هو
كبر حجم التيارات السياسيه والاطراف الذين
يريدون المشاركه في القرار السياسي في
بلادهم وهذا من حقهم وفي نفس الوقت الفقر
الشديد في مؤسسه المجلس الانتقالي الوطني
ببناءها الحالي الذي لا يستطيع ان يستوعب
كل هذه السيارات
هل هم يعني
مشتتين على صعيد القياده بمعنى ان كل
مجموعه لها قيادتها وبالتالي هناك تحدي
جمع وتوحيد هؤلاء في بوقاقه واحده عسكريه
نعم نعم طرابلس مرينا بتجارب الان الامن
في طرابلس مبني على توازن الرعب هناك
اطراف مسلحه كل واحد ربما بالنسبه ليبيا
عايش في طرابلس هو مثل الاشباح لا اعتقد
ان الامن في ليبيا الامن في طرابلس الان
هو مدار بطريقه محترفه ام المصنع بكل معنى
الكلمه اعتقد ان هو توازن رعب بين مجموعات
مختلفه تحمل السلاح وكل واحده تتراقبه
الاخرى وهذا طبعا وضع خطير اعتقد انه
يحتاج الى حكومه مركزيه بدون حكومه مركزيه
لن يكون هناك
الاستقرار في البلاد والحكومه المركزيه
تحتاج الى تطوير المنظومه السياسيه للمجلس
الانتقالي الوطني بحيث تستطيع ان يرضي كل
الاطراف يستطيع ان يسمح بمشاركه كل
التيارات السياسيه
الذين يرغبون في صناعه في المشاركه في
صناعه القرار الوطني
باسم المجلس العسكري من بنغازي عن هذه
النقطه وموضوع توحيد الثوار ولجم الفوضى
على الارض
صيد انيس
يعني نحن لا لا نشهد في الايام القليله
المقبله عن اعلان مظله عامه تضم الغالبيه
العظمى من ثوار ليبيا كهيئه تنسيقيه
ياتيلافيه تمثل الثوار في كافه البلاد
ويتم خلال التنسيق في اتخاذ المواقف وفي
التعامل مع القضايا المستقبليه بما فيها
قضيه
السلاح وغيرها من القضايا الذي يريد ان
يشير اليه هنا ان في موضوع السلاح بالذات
لا اعتقد انه بعد هذا الثمن الباهض الذي
دفعه الليبيون
ثمنا لهذه الحريه الغاليه التي وصلنا
اليها انه يمكن ان يسمح الشعب الليبي
بعمومه وبمشمانه بما في ذلك الثوار ان
يسمحوا لاي طرف ان يدخل البلاد في مغامره
اخرى مساله جمع السلاح هي تريد ان لابد ان
تاتي ضمن مشروع وطني عام ياتي في اطار
اعاده تشكيل الجيش الليبي وفق عقيده جديده
انيس من الذي يسيطر على هؤلاء المسلحين
وبمن ياتمرون
يعني نحن نعرف ان هناك كثير من التشكيلات
في كثير من المدن
الغالبيه العظمى منها منظاويه تحت
ائتلافات محليه داخل هذه المدن في اطار
كتائب عسكريه او في شكل مجالس عسكريه وفي
او ضمن اطار سرايا للثوار او مشابه الفكره
او المشروع المطروح المقبل هو محاوله
انشاء مظله وطنيه عامه واتيلا وطني عام
ليكون المظله العامه التي تعبر عن الاراء
الثوار لكن اعود ليكمل فكرتي عن موضوع جمع
السلاح لابد ان ياتي ضمن لا يمكن ان ياتي
هذا بقرار صادر فقط من غير ان
بتنسيق وبطرح هذه الرؤيه ونقاشها مع
المعنيين بالامر وهم الكتائب وهم هؤلاء
الثوار لجمعهم ومحاوله ادماجهم في مشروع
الدوله المقبل سواء ضمن المشروع العسكري
في الجيش او في الاطرني او في ضمن المشروع
الاصعب بالتحديد لانها تدخل في مفاوضات
بين السياسيين والعسكريين اشكرك جزيلا
انيس الشريف المتحدث الاعلامي باسم المجلس
العسكري من بنغازي واشكر من طرابلس عز
الدين عقيل الكاتب والباحث السياسي ومن
بنغازي ايضا عبد الحفيظ غوقا نائب رئيس
المجلس الوطني الانتقالي الليبي بهذا
مشاهدينا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر غدا باذن الله قراءه جديده
فيما وراء خبر جديد الى اللقاء